y había una facultad vierta de árabe en vuelva para dos faloninos.
Vale, yo te digo que no haya cosa en concluencia.
En vuelva tenían derecho a tener filología árabe porque yo tenía derecho.
No, pero si ahora una cerrá porque no haya colándolo de esto.
No la cerraron porque dijeron que le iban a cerrar y entonces se puso el alcalde en vuelva y todo a vuelva porque allí yo tenía derecho a tener su facultad de filología árabe.
Ahora que no quedan con coincidencia de sabras y ya casos particulares no te digo nada.
Pero lo que te dicen es que esas cosas verán con nuestros impuestos.
¿Podemos pagar esos dos alumnos de árabe?
Pero hombre, todo hay que estudiarlo, todo tiene un límite tan bien.
Pues lo falta ya no.
Que no puede generalizar porque si tú generalizas muchas cosas ahí se agarra mucho también.
O sea, es más y estudiar los casos particulares ya lo mejor sí, a lo mejor no.
Que generalizar que todo lo que no sea rentable no...
Pues te digo que yo no sé el caso de todo de tu colegio.